well it's officially March which
apparently means that is now time for
the movies relating to partying and
alcohol to be released 21 and over let's
talk about it 21 and over is exactly
that it is a movie about someone who
just turned 21 for the first night and
his friends are gonna take him out and
get him wasted and it's gonna be a big
fun night of partying and lots of things
we're gonna happen things are gonna get
broken
lots of bear mail butts are gonna be
seen lots of alcohol lots and lots of
music and lots of insane partying now if
you guys can tell anything about me from
my videos I'm not much of a partier I am
able to have fun without getting drunk
I do enjoy an occasional drink from time
to time I'm just not much of a partier
nothing against you if you are so going
in this movie I wasn't really that
excited about it because I can just see
it for what it is this is a giant copy
off of Project X if you don't believe me
let me give you a few things to think
about Project X came out last year on
March 2nd this movie is being released
exactly one year later on March 1st this
movie honestly is a giant copy off of
Project X it just doesn't have the
handheld style Project X was a big copy
off of super bad which was much better
with real characters that you could
actually care about now I didn't really
enjoy Project X and I got a few comments
on my review that said that the reason I
didn't like it was simply because I'm
not a partier that's not true because I
really enjoyed super bad that movie had
good characters that I actually started
to care about it was well-written and it
was legitimately funny I didn't find
Project X to be and I don't really find
this movie that funny either but it's
just so blatant how these movies all
have this very rigid thing that they
actually fall right into okay like you
can see every little thing it has to
have for instance in Superbad Jonah's
character was the instigator he was the
guy who always got them into trouble he
was the guy who always started
everything he was the guy who said I'm
your friend but he really wasn't being
your friend he says whatever is on his
mind whenever he wants to and he's not
really a lady's guy but he hits on every
single lady as if they are all just want
him in Project X that character was
casta that person was the person who got
everything started he was the big
partier who said whatever was on his
mind who talked to all the ladies like
they all wanted him even though they
didn't in this movie that character's
name is Miller and he is played by miles
teller he's the guy who says hey I'm
your friend but he's not really your
friend he's the guy who comes in and
starts everything gets everything going
each one of these movies has that this
movie has that as well the entire movie
a night of extreme situations in which
everything goes wrong just like super
bad just like Project X and towards the
end of the movie there's usually some
sort of resolution in which everyone
realizes they're actually really good
friends they come together and
everything's happy and let's have a
montage with whatever current pop song
is on the radio now look you guys are
looking at me like this guy's such a
douchebag he doesn't have fun at all I'm
sorry I just when I watch movies like
this I can't help but notice there's a
guy in a suit somewhere in a studio
going okay does this movie have the the
instigator yes it does okay does it have
lots of you know random nudity that
doesn't really make sense and lots of
events like you know cars exploding and
people jumping off roofs and all that
kind of stuff it has that right okay
good good good and at the end is there
some sort of resolution which everyone
becomes friends again they realize how
great parting is and they don't really
actually have to take responsibility for
anything as long as they're drunk
forever everything's fine right good
sign-off it'll make lots of money make
it do it I can't help but notice that
when I see movie like this and 21 and
over really is just another retread of
all these types of movies and it's not
very funny there was a couple chuckle
worthy moments that I thought were okay
but for the most part this movie is
filled with terrible acting terrible
characters and terrible dialogue and you
just don't care about any of the story
really and it's just honestly watching a
whole bunch of people get drunk why is
that fun you know I mean if you want to
go out and get drunk go out and get
drunk it's not fun to sit there and just
watch other people get drunk for 90
minutes and nothing entertaining happens
21 and over like I said it's just a big
copy off of other movies it follows
their rigid guideline that this type of
movie is required nowadays and it's
really blatant in every way in regards
to ripping off Project X right down to
the release date I'm gonna give 21 and
over a d-plus it's not that good if you
like these types of movies go out and
watch it and have fun that's cool man
it's just not my kind of movie at all
thanks a lot for watching guys if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
you